j'ai des amis dans ma chambre de mon
petit-fils et le grenier
jamais jamais ont pas le jeu le plus
difficile que le son jeu est ma vie je
me suis fait envahir j'exigerai de
récupérer ma chambre où ce serait la
guerre tu veux pas qu'ils attaquent son
grand-père déclaration de guerre
tu as quelque chose qui m'appartient je
veux le récupérer mais loisel en
facturation assurances ce genre
d'agression peut pas être ignorée sur le
grand père nous warhammer
[Musique]
je répète que l'échec à mal
oh que ça surtout pas de cette pièce
c'est vraiment la guerre passer une
bonne journée à l'école aux bisous
précédent montrer plus malin que mon
petit-fils moines en pleine lutte pour
une chambre
j'ai bien eu je t'aurais prévenu
surveillance et son recul à ok quelle
belle équipe veut fait les deux je suis
pas au courant pendant la guerre de
paris
ouais
c'est vraiment amusée je vous propose
mon jeu
bon je vois aux idées